all right one last one I'm all of this
entire process okay as you can see it's
oh yeah if I'm buying and selling a
single share not that complicated
okay however in reality generally we're
buying and selling hundreds of shares
it's risky and we're doing it over like
multiple companies bought what okay you
entrust all this kind of stuff to
someone else who we call a broker in
order to manage its entire versus
because you know they can get both
discounts and all that kind of thing and
they know what they're doing now none of
this is free so beer that they called a
broker a fee that they charge is called
brick Ridge okay brick region brokerage
is a fee it tends to be a percentage
which is charged on like you buy more
shares they're going to charge you more
okay so this is a broker's fee and you
should take usually a percentage of the
actual value you're buying usually a
percentage the burkas fee for carrying
out your transactions maybe buying and
selling all that kind of stuff
okay so these 1 2 3 4 pieces are enough
for us to get started you can write this
first example up here I haven't finished
writing it actually so we're going to
look at a really brief example you'll
see a lot of the maths that we use at
least the beginning is very simple and
almost identical to stuff you put that
before in terms like calculating
interest and so on there's a as
multiplying that's adding this
percentages not complicated but you must
pay attention to the language because
they're asking different pieces ok so
first example questions let me fish it
off question yeah probably not
I don't know how I would feel if like
her dad came in on me show you guys like
okay sir so yes or no so I'm putting
this hundred-percent here because what
you're going to get out is an armoire
and it has a % so to then number two and
two hundred percents are the same number
yeah so I actually it matters that I say
percent at the end so in some ways it's
really just to say like what what simple
what units am I going to put out to this
so if you didn't have it there and you
are to 200 like it so you wouldn't put
that directly into your calculator
should you put that into your calculator
yeah
but the actual else you provide you'd
say two hundred percent like you must
say two hundred percent okay so we're
going to work out what's the total cost
of purchasing 600 shares at simple stuff
first and like I said when we did FM one
and we were looking at like earning a
salary or wages or whatever it's really
important you don't just do numbers but
you say what you're working out okay so
here's what I'm going to start with I'm
gonna say total market value okay
total market value of course it refers
to I've got a market value but what
happens when they get all of these
shares this exact quantity what's going
to happen right each individual one cost
that amount so this is simple this is
just 600 by their market value okay you
can solo calculate that point
I'm not gonna be faster actually getting
out my calculator slowly game in please
someone surely will baby
2006 I get it okay so this my total
value that's that's how much I'm
actually going to get worth of shares
but I've got to pay someone in order to
actually do this transaction for me so
I'm gonna write down now rookery equals
what would you take that you write down
for your next line of working two point
three percent times that right or you
can do them in either way because we can
multiply in any direction I'm going to
go so this this by the way is equivalent
to things like every time you do
significant transactions there is always
someone in the middle who charge you for
part of it okay
the most common person in the middle is
the government right so for example even
when you go out and you buy a pair of
shoes you pay for what what kind of bit
- they take out they take out GST I'm
free financial advice but it's
okay okay so got a really good question
don't answer the question was can I just
buy a single shift now the answer in
theory is yes it's the reason well
especially when like I mentioned um
especially when some of their companies
wasn't really taking off you'd buy a
single share like Proctor and addicts
like can see here it was like thousands
of dollars one of the harshest whatever
was same theory yes however if your
shares are of this kind of value which
one you have a look at the stock
exchange is not that uncommon it's quite
frequent this brokerage is actually a
simplification right usually they will
not just charge your percentage just
like for normal Commission they'll
charge you like an upfront fee I've been
having fun that initial cost like when
you're publishing in whatever it's like
yeah you got to spend like say maybe
fifty dollars just to get your foot in
the door spend $4 35 on the share and
spend $50 on the brokerage fee there's
not much appointment really okay so
anyone is to use that this is operating
in the hundreds or thousands of shares
someone got a number for you
62.83 exact cool okay so what have I got
now is the actual shares on by and then
how much goes to this broker now I just
want to combine it right
so therefore turn all costs
well I like I said because what you're
doing is by more than just an object
you're buying into like a legal
relationship so because of all the legal
stuff right like most people are not
qualified to do that kinda because what
peg works and know exactly what you're
doing
sian all the spot to be able to vouch
for okay this has been done legally I've
done all the checks this is not just
some random person
they're usually laws on who can be a
shareholder all the company like you
have to be a permanent resident or a
citizen all those kinds of things mean
that this is more than just buying an
object so correct there's got to be
there's got to be something worth it so
you got to go for significance so this
is like two six seven and three cents